[Gelächter]
sie besuchen andere welt bewaffnet mit
vor die kamera und taschenlampe
sie stiegen die ihn verlassen die haie
vergessen die gebäude lost places
171 laden ihn wo die luft ja eigentlich
nicht entschieden dass mediziner der
blick kritischer so dass seine
nachkommen sich hier und nicht um was
kümmern
überrascht bin labour-chef
wechsel gibt es oft die ganze welt sehen
den ehrenkodex doch nicht alle befolgen
alle punkt und das finden
[Musik]
was nützlich
wenn du das nicht wieder
offline nehmen schon 40 aber wo die
jäger volllast places zugang hand können
da lüthi niveau novellieren es gibt
strache wird mühe haben den sachwert
fonds sind oder
einfach am boden werfen und einfach
david gems für das perfekte otti und was
macht das mit einer lost places
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und vergessen die gebäude gibt es in der
ganzen schweiz verteilt als ich wirklich
faszinierend wenn wir da auf social
media ökologe was wir da alles findet
aber was man weg findet sind geo tags
also oft weiß man nicht genau wo die art
sind und das kürzen guten ton wie durban
explorers nicht verraten wo genau die
art sind dass man ihre der reportage
übrigens auch nicht will mit masse
tourismus einer vergessenen ort förderer
aber
[Musik]
nicht alle denken dass so ein begleiter
heute zwei sonden exploring expedition
lost places thailand mit öffentlichkeit
was riesige diskussionen ausgelöst hatte
die szene und zeigt sogar schon der
ruhige korrekt weg geben
natürlich
was mit ihrer reportage andere
spezialisten dass man kann nicht
wirklich die person in einer wo das
hobby machen will eigentlich sowie legal
und deshalb werde müsse jetzt eine
mitnahme und genau mit gesicht kennen
lernen ja das würde durch vielleicht
bisher keine spezielle reportagen wir
machen
die zwei wochen ich begleite machen das
sieht mehrere jahre die zwei freunde hat
sich in airbags vor keine bleibt immer
an buchungen sind unterwegs wie die
ganze schweiz also zerstörung oder jetzt
so kantig alte bäckerei sie stolz sind
mehrere besitzer gestorben sind und dir
wo das dann kauft erhält jetzt einfach
noch nicht wissen was du machen und das
jetzt einfach mal und deshalb ist das
jetzt ein prime lost place
hier und ich liege
da kannst du ihn genommen
dahinter glaubt
dass
sie mit lauter verkauf die sind halt
verstorbenen vermutlich ein wendepunkt
verpasst womit minister sage jetzt mal
verkaufen
also eigentlich sehr
heikel ist wichtig um eine
durchschnittliche teuerung miterleben
und
zwei schnitte gott rain sitzen in den
slawen jena.de lüth ja eigentlich nicht
entscheiden das mittel dienen der blicke
gerichtet ist so präsent ist eine niere
nachkomme es sich hier nicht um das
kümmern und dann geht es hat etwas was
situationen das manöver soll bis z wie
jetzt unter anderem
wo eigentlich noch alles durch wie wenn
dir jetzt gott schnell waren geborsten
irgendwie
ist es wichtig dass meine theken die
aber bis kaputt macht oder gott
gespräche sondern gegner
dahinter heizen nur lebensmittel
mein szenario
man hat jetzt sogar jim lettisch
alkohol
[Musik]
das schon heikel objekte war und so
also glaube wenn ich zum ersten mal sagt
er weil jetzt nicht so selbstsicher der
ja
eigentlich tatsächlich die reporter
direkt
geschafft ja
und da bin ich eigentlich wirklich
relativ
aufmerksam und hat einfach weltkrieg und
ich bin jetzt
stockwerk purzelte
zombie
ausgerechnet denn wenn ihr leichen und
der wachs sie darum empfiehlt sich das
abonnierte
alleine auf tools
co-leiter
bilder wo sie machen landen oft auf
blogs und auf social media und überall
ist von codecs vor dem wechsel das
wichtigste land muss seine fahrspur und
im neat mit unser twitter ließ
aber um schnüffeln
ja gewohnt dass auch ich sagen ich bin
es gewohnt rick das training abbrechen
sagte susanne also ich mach einfach
sterling austria die macher schublade
nun flog tree macht werde ich der fifa
spannendem dann mach ja wohl dazu
es ist vor allem der zerfall wo sie
absolut faszinierend findet geschichte
von damals wo irgendwann einfach
nicht
[Musik]
hält den dänischen küste
auf mit dem leader schafft wird das
macht uns der wunder überwiegt denn je
aber das bin ich mir bewusst dass
künftig wird er sich wohl krise
ist das naiv ich
[Musik]
habe dort meine leser auch ist möglich
also ich kann die faszination absolut
verstorben aber ich kann absolut alles
teurer sagend sind sie wahnsinnig 2001
privat zeigen wohin bringt also ich weiß
nicht ob mir das
mittelohr wir quasi man sich einst das
soja kuka bischof genn eingeschränkt er
steht einfach
[Musik]
das studio hofft bilder von generalen so
hell der bild es ist dass wir alles zu
kurz und war sie deswegen übrigens auch
airbags es kann gut sein dass da etwas
anders des führers kurz vor dem abi
[Musik]
überrascht bin labour-chef
das ist ja ich bin der haube haben ihn
auch überraschend fing
ja mit spinnenphobie und schimmel an
stunde allgemein selber glaubt das hobby
die macher das wäre glaube ich muss
sehen wir
hier glaube ich angst vor geistern
erwischt das hat mich somit verwischt
werden weil ich angst davor
dass sich so viele orte pixi ist das
relativ wenig passiert aber wenn der
begriff vielleicht mal auf einer
fußabwehr darauf nach
branche klare entwicklung
angestoßen polizei
man muss schon relativ viel bach hat es
das passiert aber das ist eben riesa
bewusst passieren
wird polizei hilft und
ich will dich da zeigt also geld
eigentlich genial wenn ihr noch
irgendwas ich muss friedens buchmacher
ja was ja geldstrafe bis zu drei jahre
knast kampeter ja gar nicht das buch
natürlich pixel also
600 menschen verstanden also mein halt
dass geberit zuständig ist definitiv das
war das gebäude ist zudem eine biene und
wenn alle türen offen ist denn hat man
wirklichkeit das man je nach aber wenn
das gebäude zuerst dann ist es zu es
blieb zur und die wenigen die noch mal
nach dem ersten hören auf gott das
gebäude ist zu und man hat einfach da
und ich habe die nachricht keine bilder
machen
gar nicht wie sonst alles klar
das war's noch wenn wir es anstrich
langsam nina
hoss ab dänisches einbruch um
hausfriedensbruch
ob denn wenn man denn verwischt werden
und irgendeiner seite aber hat das
fenster gestern ganz kritisiert und zwar
nicht kaputt denn ist das ganz schwach
das ist unglaublich realisiert dass man
eine halbe stunde lang den accent dz so
gemacht
kaserne spanne von haben wir ihnen
geschmeckt hätte also sich so wirklich
schmeckt noch altgeld das ist ganz
typisch lost place das motto ja das ist
ganz glücklich
der auch sie sind gefragt ob man da
dürfen filme will ja natürlich villa im
vereinshaus fans buchberger
deshalb im oktober können was ist das
jetzt mehr wüsste dass jetzt schätze ist
dass das sehr gut konserviert lost place
oder geschätzt
da hat es ganz viel richtig ganz viel
sache wo
wohnen sie es geht bei vandalismus es
ist nicht versteht wie lebe eigentlich
ist kein offizieller also offiziell ist
aber es ist möglich schlossen ivg zum
risiko jetzt können wir das war wohl
bislang
so stark rock tenn die ach ja genau wo
wir also das kind überhaupt zum
ölwechsel dazu dass es irgendwie heißt
es war verboten oder das ist nicht mehr
persönlich war soll wenn's nicht
reporter war also dass das macht für
mich jetzt nicht dazu und
für mich sagte van dyck nachfrage oder
der praxis wenig zu machen und so
wichtig aber es geht nicht nur auf die
routine also das ist absolut
möglich also darum wird ihm zeigt es ist
einfach besonders kapitel art wäre wenn
wir das so bedienen das
einkommen wächst und wächst zunächst
location bis die selige finden könnt
gerne mal ein paar stunden frei sie
suchen google maps und die lokale presse
noch so verlassene gebäude ab
wir sind dennoch um dumme
sie teilte auch das immer gewundert mit
der öffentlichkeit für viele airbags
gott das gar nichts
ich danke mir so wenige große ufer und
urs betriebe zum die locations ums eck
wende er bringt sein hofer andere
lediglich aufwand minister machen und
schon addio der haare es braucht einfach
viel energie wie für solche egoistische
argument
irgendwie ja wenn die griechen die
kostet dann ist das eben eine coole idee
in der mine verteile oder niesen ist
nicht weniger werden nun will jessica
und nützliche hacker aber schon nur
krass dass das so zufälliges thema nicht
dass das sogar gekriegt
die jako um drittes album macht ruhig
kurz leute die am anfang was nötig sei
porsche bringt jung wenn du das und das
nicht wieder
offline nehmen schon 70 aber zum glück
nur mal ganz wenige und nun also schon
lang lang nimmer
das wissen trotzdem work up mustafi
mit mango prognostizieren
also was ist denn jetzt ja das industrie
thalgo in spezieller
das mit der troika also da geht's
wirklich sehr darüber aufregen wenn etwa
auf der website oder instagram zum
beispiel genau acht teils
echt krass und ja das muss wirklich
nicht die große liebe schafft sich wenn
man sich so gar nicht so sachen umschlag
passau risiko gott will also größte
ausdauer anna schreiber kein zutritt
kasseler klinik also wenn die wiko
meiner
was stocker stücke zeigen es nichts was
man jetzt aber du für deine lakaien
heftig viele besitzer von gebäude den
verschiedenen wirklich nicht mit so
großem interesse an dem haus und dennis
alberding lockt theoretisch aber
praktisch ist es soweit sein unfall geht
belegen wir morgen wird steige therapeut
will die nummer sicher ist dann haftet
der besitzer oder besitzerin für den
unfall und das ist der grund wieso viele
aber sagen nein
schonnebeck
gelaufen
gebäude
ja spannend und das jetzt quasi das
risiko ist
ein wenig größer die musik einkaufen
müssen
wenn industrie über die sonst nicht oder
normalerweise herrscht seit tagen der
seite scharf stellt dazu fest mit einem
artist uhr und das sind das ein riesiger
handel wird hat unglaubliche perspektive
den und dennoch schaue mit dem das
teilte standorten zurück gemacht worden
ist das war sehr
spannenden ort und ich denke das risiko
des art
wir sind jetzt akku als letzter art vom
heutigen tag als ehemaliges
und was man natürlich immer gehört in
zusammenhang mit urban explorer das
thema vandalismus
grafitti
eingeschlagene fenster und so weiter und
so fort
und da ich jetzt ein ort nur definitiv
wann der lernt war oder nicht und
unterwegs aber sehr bekannt ist also das
hat nicht schon verschiedene nordsee und
auch sie zwei sind schon mal dass sie
gern mehr
als eigentlich
der urteilt haut gleich ganz spezielle
also nicht auch der atmosphäre
wo man ist wieder spannend finden
ob der universalismus lässt sich
sagen die iren zu dem ganzen organismus
besser machen das nicht das ist klar
abgrenzen
mit seine dominante so
bezeichnet wechsel wurden das machen
sondern möglich
vor allem
verstößt laut oder nicht aber mir haben
und jetzt ist mit völlig zerstört
da ich wohl schon jeder erwachsene
es ist masse tourismus
aber für lüth wo wandel ihren als ein
versprechen
verbraucht wurde
ich werde da übrigens nicht illegal ich
habe keine bewilligung in konz
deutsche zeichner von der nidda mit ruf
brauch geworden ist es hat aber
vier oder fünf gegangen war jetzt offen
sind
wenn immobilien mehrere jahre politisch
das nicht nur für den explorer sondern
auch für von der leyen und wenn die
einst ins gebäudeinnere kommt können die
anderen arena deshalb gibt es viele
hausbesitzer wo garnier atome haben auch
nicht hier wo ein lied nur während
vettel
[Musik]
zwischen der neuen art gelandet
erstmalig seit 46 jahren leer steht und
da will man wirklich
blogger das keine kunst deshalb gibt es
da auch noch ein hausmeister wohl ab und
zu im hotel guide kann man wirklich
sänger und zum rechten lockt
das start sehr sogar
aber weiter trotzdem ab und zu auch
fragen nicht erwünscht ist noch jung
[Musik]
ja das ist jetzt so gesagt aus wenn
ihnen kommen und die vw kontrolleure
ja einfach aufbrauchen und
ist eine video beruf und
aber wenn man nicht mehr macht dänisches
prüfe meine zusätzlich ein sturm mit
aber gar nicht andromaque ist
und was macht mitglied wird dafür
wirklich demokratische polizei haben
sache wenn ich jetzt gesehen designer
etwas wirklich gebucht oder so dann
erstmal polizei hat brach aber so stunde
sehr mahner ist eine durch
also das ist jetzt da eingeteilt vor dem
hotel wo
seereederei staub fischer durfte möbel
das ist krass und gerade als problem
vorwege klar oder vandalismus willst du
wirklich noch viel härter könnte
jetzt da das ist ein elternteil vor dem
hotel dass ich wirklich los place sie
dem sehen wo einem als fotograf oder
fotografen wird interessieren als erbin
explorer und der lieblings auch zu uns
möchte
er kann erben explorer uhr verstarb und
zur wii kommen zum fotografieren für
mandala butt gar kein verständnis
das problem ist das gebäude ist zum teil
sehr alt und dementsprechend fällt da
will niemand verantwortung für den fall
übernehmen
[Musik]
was
er macht das ehrenamtlich also er
telefoniert zahlt zum das mache und ich
frage mich sowieso
dass frau genia kultur
was ich wie die dort wachsen bieten und
das hotel ich
bin irgendwie mit dem einbezug wachsen
und komisches möglich was da passiert
und rom mache dass sie das wenn er mag
den kurs relativ schnell und deniz dogan
sie schauen und gebucht
ich kann wirklich jeder verstorben oder
ist absolut faszinierend findet irgendwo
ein wenig schwierig ist deshalb verboten
und vor allem japan der lehrer
muss echt nicht sie aber verstanden alle
fotografinnen und fotografen
das ist ein witz in den topf ihnen
gehört fühlen mit denen was eigentlich
nicht richtig ist hey was meinst du zu
dem thema zu der reportage zu deiner
alten gebäude
würde mich sehr wundern und auch die
bürger die beantwortet ihnen den service
aber doch dieser kanal und dort aus per
video podcast